whoa that's an uplifting movie in that
Christmas spirit collateral beauty so
collateral Beauty stars Will Smith whose
character lost his daughter tragically
sometime before this movie started so he
writes letters to death time and love
and puts them in the mailbox and the
embodiments of death time and love come
to him so we can reconcile these
emotions so we could you know live a
happy life and that's the premise the
trailer told you I don't know how to
review this movie without actually
setting up the actual premise of the
movie I don't find it particularly
spoiler it can be categorized as spoiler
ish since it is not addressed in the
trailer and the trailer does not brace
you for any of it so I'm going to give
you a few seconds to step off if you
would find that spoiler ish so here you
go if you're still around I assume you
want the actual setup for the actual
movie right here's the setup
so collateral Beauty stars Edward Norton
who's supporting character friend played
by Will Smith tragically lost his
daughter some time before this movie
started Will Smith's character writes
letters to death time and love in order
to reconcile his emotions and somehow
cope with it so Edward Norton Kate
Winslet and Michael Pena his friends and
colleagues find three actors to come to
Will Smith and pretend that they are the
embodiment of death time and love so he
can look crazy and they can get him out
of the company so they can get money
it's not really spoilers that's just the
setup as the movie just gives you the
set up in the beginning it's almost like
the trailer to a Christmas carol is like
Jacob Marley comes to Ebenezer Scrooge
in the ghost of past present and future
Christmas come to him and so Polly
becomes a good person he's not a dick
anymore when in reality the actual movie
or player whatever is every nezer
Scrooge's friend finds Jacob Marley's
twin to come to him and act like the
ghost of Jacob Marley and then they find
three actors to play the ghost of
Christmas past present and future and
it's all actually a sham I'm just saying
trying to keep it honest alright Will
Smith is a great actor and he can drive
us to tears because you can bring the
audience to tears because he's Will
Smith I mean the guy started out as a
rapper now he's one of the best actors
working right now that's no small feat
and the dude brings it in this movie it
really does it's a tear-jerking movie
but it is definitely tear jerking bait
the movie exists simply to bring the
audio
two tears so you walk out of there going
I cried in there yeah I might address
again Helen Mirren is the most
attractive 25 year old ever Saint Helen
single but the movie does in the end
have a sweet message about dealing with
pain and not giving up and if you accept
the pain then there is a good life to be
lived pain is a part of life and so is
death and this is not the end of the
world doesn't change the fact the pacing
in this movie sometimes is ballz slow
yeah this movie could have been like a
half an hour shorter I've probably
closer to 15 minutes but it feels like a
half an hour only God knows it yeah it
could have been half an hour shorter and
whether or not you're going to enjoy
this movie it all depends on your mood
what you're going for there's a lot of
movies coming out this time of year man
all the Oscar bait movies are making
their push all that Christmas movies are
making their push and in the middle
somewhere it's collateral beauty and
among the tangled web that is weaved in
this movie of emotions and connections
really is a celebration of human
connection I get all of it I saw all of
it I caught all of it in the end I don't
know the movie is worth saying hey yeah
total I got to go out and watch this one
I'll say the movie be better if you were
drunk yeah no this is blurry right guys
so collateral Beauty have you seen it
what did you think of Star Wars rogue
one let's be honest here whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to say more
[Music]
you
[Music]